ينضم الينا من امام مستشفى ثابت ثابت في
طولكرم مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار الليث
تطورات اخر المستجدات للعمليه العسكريه
التي تابعناها حتى صباح
اليوم نعم يعني انسحب الاحتلال من مخيم
نور شمس بعد عمليه عسكريه استمرت ع ساعات
في هذا المخيم تخللها اشتباكات مسلحه
وانفجارات لعش لعشرات العبوات الناسفه كما
تشاهدون في هذه الصوره حاله من الدمار
الواسع التي خلفها الاحتلال بعد تدمير
البنا التحتيه من شبكات الصرف الصحي شبكات
المياه الكهرباء وايضا الطرقات هنا في
مدخل المخيم في منطقه المنشيه في منطقه
جبل النصر حيث هل يمكنك تحديد مكان تواجدك
اكثر نعم
نعم نحن الان نتواجد امام مدخل مخيم نور
شمس الرئيسي الذي قام الاحتلال بتدميره
بشكل كامل يعني كما تشاهدون في هذه الصوره
وهي ليست المره الاولى التي يقوم بها
الاحتلال بتدمير شبكات الصرف الصحي شبكات
المياه وكافه البناه التحتيه في المخيم
هذا المدخل تم او قام المخيم باصلاحه
عشرات المرات الا ان الاحتلال في كل مره
وفي كل اقتحام يقوم بتدمير البنى التحتيه
تدمير شبكات الصرف الصحي شبكات المياه
وايضا الكهرباء هذه حقيقه ليس فقط هذا
الشارع وانما في هذا في هذه المره عده
طرقات عده طرقات تم تدميرها في المدخل
الرئيسي ايضا في منطقه المنشيه وايضا جبل
النصر ادى هذا الاقتحام لارتقاء خمسه
شهداء وايضا عدد من الاصابات تم نقلهم الى
مستشفى ثابت ثابت الحكومي انسحب الاحتلال
بشكل كامل من المخيم وكاميرات الجزيره تمت
او قامت برصد هذا الانسحاب بعشرات العبوات
الناسفه التي فجرت اثناء انسحابها وايضا
تم رصد حاله الانسحاب نحو بوابه 104 او ما
تسمى بتسني عوز الى الغرب من مدينه طول
كرم